why should I know my why when I'm either
an entrepreneur nor a manager but a
regular president or employee who just
wants to improve first of all you don't
have to learn your wife you don't want
to learn it the first criterion of being
a leader is my friend General George
Flinn explains to me the first criterion
to be a leader is you have to want to be
one I never try and twist anybody's arm
to learn there why even if I know in the
core of my being that it'll help them
whether it's to find joy in their life
join their relationships joy in their
work my rule is if you you have to ask
me if you want to find your way so I'll
of course help my friends but and I tell
my friends the answer is gonna be yes
but I'm you have to you have to ask and
so to the cheeki breeki book club if you
don't wanna know it you don't want to
know it that's fine but what I do know
is is that knowing your why is and
having that sense of foundation it
builds confidence
I mean Iram I can think back that when I
learned my why the first thing that
happened to me was this overwhelming
sense of calm a calm confident
confidence came over me I'm much more
certain about decisions I make
personally and professionally because at
the end of the day it doesn't matter if
you're an entrepreneur or you're or a
manager you're a human being and this is
a human this is a human experience so I
hope you do want to learn your why one
day because I can tell you that it's a
magical experience and it puts you on an
entirely new path for the rest of your
life
[Music]
you